until you make more
than the guy who taught you that system
you do the system exactly the way that
it was outlined
[Music]
what's going on everyone i wanted to
bring this video to you downtown coming
in hot from austin uh what i want to
talk about today is a saying that we
have said over and over and over again
in our community and some real world
applications to it
and that saying is don't be cute and so
the first time i heard this saying was
from a serial ceo he was a mercenary ceo
so basically that is is a ceo who's you
know once a company like a private
equity firm purchases a new company they
go have this kind of black book of their
their all-star players their swat team
that they drop in so that they can grow
the company right that's kind of how it
works
and so he's one of these ceos he's one
of these guys that's brought into a deal
they get the company and then he grows
it again for the private equity usually
in a three to five year span and then
they exit he's done this exit process
four times and he was the one who told
me this story
and so he was like hey don't be cute he
has this long island accent um and i was
like i don't really know what that means
he's like alright so you know when
you're playing backyard football
i'm not even trying to the accent and i
was like yeah and he's like so you've
got
two you know you try and make these
super fancy plays you're like alright
we're gonna go fake left and then double
fake right and then we're gonna swing
around and then you're gonna pretend to
be the quarterback and then i'm gonna
throw it that way right he's like what
happens he's like you try it and then
you know tommy fumbles the ball and you
lose 10 yards and you lose the ball
right he's like instead he's like
put the two fat guys in the middle run
to the right right and what is that he's
like consistent yardage and he's like
don't be cute and so that story has
always stuck with me because it's so
true in business and that's what he was
applying it to
but i feel like so many of the
entrepreneurs that i talk to and the
ones that we work with um a lot of times
you know myself included like we try and
be cute and we try and get fancy when
it's usually the fundamentals that breed
success and one of the biggest telltale
signs i think of somebody who's newer is
that they do not repeat successful
actions and that's there's two types of
successful actions there's successful
actions that you do that yield a good
result and you think oh i did that that
worked let me go try and do something
else rather than doing more of that
thing right that's the first way the
second way is where you're paying for a
system or you're paying for advice or
whatever and the person says do it this
way
and then you do not repeat their
successful action and so this is one
where a lot of times i feel like we need
to be reminded more than we need to be
taught and this is one of those
instances because
over the last probably week i've had
three separate conversations um two with
entrepreneurs who are doing about three
million a year and one with a brand new
entrepreneur my uh my neighbor i think
i've referenced them before
and when i was talking to my neighbor he
just bought this system so he can start
flipping real estate and he's doing well
um and
you know he was he was like i think i
might do it this way and i was like
listen
until you make more
than the guy who taught you that system
you do the system exactly the way that
it was outlined all right you don't
don't get cute don't think you're you're
special don't think you're a snowflake
just do it exactly as it's outlined
because there's a reason it's outlined
that way
and the two entrepreneurs that i talked
to who are on our agency side who are
doing about three million a year we just
did a call and i was like hey what are
your wins from this last month and both
of them were like you know
you know we've been doing we've been
trying a lot of stuff and
finally we decided to just
you know do it the way that you had
outlined it and we're actually seeing a
lot better results and um they said it
kind of the tone was like i don't have
reluctance the right word but like
feeling feeling silly right
um about themselves that they had taken
this long to do that right
and the reason i'm bringing this up is
that if you purchase a system if you
take advice if you watch a youtube video
of somebody who's doing better than you
at something which is why you're trying
to learn right and they're doing it a
specific way there's a reason that
they're doing it that way it's probably
because they have the same goal that you
do and probably suffer from the same
cons that you suffer from and they've
already balanced those for the best
outcome right
and so
recently this morning i was on um a call
with our marketing uh team our traffic
guys and i was looking at our
funnel that were optim we're in the
process of optimizing
and my traffic guy's like man if people
knew how much we work
on optimizing our conversion process
he's like i feel like they wouldn't want
to change anything because they know
that we've probably already tried it
and i wanted to at least pay homage to
that because right now
we're maybe
i'd say three weeks into optimizing this
conversion process of series of pages
and copy and messaging and whatnot
and even in those three weeks we've
already tested over a hundred different
pieces of this conversion process this
funnel the series of landing pages
messaging etc and so that means we've
changed the headlines a handful of times
we've changed the buttons we've changed
the flow of the pages we've changed
where each one leads multiple times and
so these iterations stack and stack and
stack and so if i'm going to eventually
show someone hey this is how it works
what do you think the chances are that
if they change something it's going to
be better
probably low right and so the thing is
is that we somehow you know i think it's
an ego thing as entrepreneurs like we
always think we're special we think
we're different we think we're smarter
or whatever um but my word of my rule of
thumb for me is until i'm doing as well
or better than the person who taught me
this thing
do not change it
replicate before you get fancy right and
so that's where you know doing the
boring work don't be cute those kind of
things we need to be reminded more than
we need to be taught like those sayings
are pervasive in our community because i
think they are the things that are the
bedrock of successful entrepreneurship
and it's repeating successful actions
and there are certain points where once
we get this conversion process optimized
where i think it should be i probably
won't change i won't be pushing as much
attention to that i'll be pushing more
of my attention towards filling the top
side right so right now we just i'm
putting enough attention on bringing in
traffic so that i can find the optimal
way of converting that traffic but once
i feel like the numbers are optimized i
probably won't tweak that very much
because now it's a successful action and
i want to repeat it as many times i
possibly can and then i'm going to be
focused all in my attention on bringing
traffic into the top of that conversion
process
and so
as a total side note because that's what
these are for i guess
if you are in the process of optimizing
something which if you're using someone
else's templates or anything like that
then use them the way they are there's a
reason they are that way but if you're
coming up from these things from scratch
what i can tell you is that after having
now done this i've done this
optimization process a zillion times in
my life now
the the headlines and the messages the
top
that literally the first one to two
things that someone reads are going to
have the biggest swing on the needle and
so many times i've spent hours and days
and weeks optimizing the bottom part the
the the images and the pages and the
sorry not the pages the um like the the
copy bullets and things like that that
are below the fold right on the
newspaper if you if you flipped it open
there's a fold and then you can flip the
second half landing pages work the same
way above the fold is what someone sees
when they land on their desktop or on
their mobile phone that's above the fold
below the fold is everything else
i routinely
have seen changes of doubling to
quadrupling the throughput of a page
meaning the percentage of people who
click to do the optimal action you want
them to do
simply by changing the sentence at the
top or the sentences at the top and the
one image that someone sees
and so if you are trying to optimize
something
if you're if you're below if you're way
below where you need to be don't even
worry about anything below the fold and
in fact you could probably spend 90
percent of your attention above the fold
and get way higher returns than your
time than everything below the fold and
i can't say the amount of times we're
literally just deleting everything below
the fold got us better better throughput
on those types of pages and actions
than even putting anything there to
begin with right and so um
just recently i changed the headline of
our landing page for uh agencies who are
going to be partnering with us for our
allen software
and uh we 3xed
the the throughput of that one page
simply by changing the headline right
and on our scheduling page which is the
third step in this process we 5xed the
throughput by removing
a headline that was there we didn't even
add anything we literally removed
something that was there and so um which
was hey you know you finished this
process the next step is this we just
took out you finished this process
basically and so people are like oh i'm
not done i need to take this next step
and so it's just this huge massive jump
by removing something that was there and
so all of this at least for me is this
continuous reinforcement that we need to
be reminded more than we need to be
taught we need to repeat successful
actions when they're there if someone
gives this advice or we're taking advice
from someone especially for paying for
that advice to not take advice is akin
to literally burning your money right
because this person or this youtuber or
this this thing that you're you're
trying to learn from this person trying
to learn from has already suffered the
consequences of trial and error and so
why would you not at least just
duplicate
replicate their process and what they're
doing first
and then when you surpass or at least
match them
then and only then you will have the
understanding of the process to improve
it and the thing is is a lot of times
people become experts because of how
many failures they have if the first
time you stepped the plate you hit a
home run
you may not know why you did that is it
because of your hip stances because when
you dropped your dropped your elbow was
because you kept your eye on the ball
like there's so many other factors but
if you want the shortcut to getting to
where you want to go
replicating other people's success
repeating successful actions both on
yourself and what other people have done
is one of the shortest paths to getting
there and so
anywho um don't be cute
don't try and get fancy don't run the
super crazy whatever play just look at
the fundamentals follow the steps only
iterate after you've duplicated the
results of the person you're trying to
learn from and so um that was my message
for you today that was top of mind
the same advice i gave the 18 year old
my neighbor who's flipping real estate
right now really proud of him
and uh the same advice i give people
we're doing three million plus a year is
don't be cute
repeat successful actions we need to be
reminded more than we taught and then
just keep doing the same things over and
over and over again and you will get
outsized returns so anyways have a happy
day
hope your marketing is converting like
crazy money um and
leading you to financial wealth and
freedom um only to realize that it is
empty in that uh in the process you will
turn most the people that who know you
secretly against you they won't
purposely tell you that but they
secretly envy you and that's okay
because i'd rather be envied than pity
so with that have an amazing day and
i'll catch you guys on the flip side bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you